una agitación poco habitual al noroeste
a orillas del mar efe están siendo
ubicados puentes flotantes o motorizados
el objetivo de la operación es
permitirles cruzar el río a decenas de
tanques y otros nombrados
se necesita de
ejercicio este ejercicio es un ejercicio
multinacional inter aliados conocido y
concebido por la usa en europa y en el
que participamos y es un ejercicio que
estaba previsto desde hace tiempo el
cruce del río tiene lugar en el marco de
diferentes europe un ejercicio militar
anual pero este año la dimensión es otra
es el despliegue más grande de soldados
norteamericanos un suelo polaco desde la
creación de la otan
[Aplausos]
por supuesto todo esto se desarrolla con
la guerra de ucrania como telón de fondo
algo a lo que hacemos seguimiento y que
representa una enorme amenaza es una
buena cosa que este ejercicio muestra
que la coordinación y la cooperación de
los aliados de la otan se desarrolla
bien
el ejercicio es arriesgado pero es un
éxito una demostración de fuerza
mientras rusia perdió recientemente un
batallón entero queriendo cruzar el río
donets
el embajador norteamericano no duda en
hablar de la amenaza que viene del oeste
pero los militares eligen palabras más
prudentes
siempre estamos listos siempre y
momentos como éste siguen reforzando y
confirmando nuestra capacidad de
trabajar juntos como países aliados
este ejercicio militar dura un mes
entero las tropas están divididas en dos
grupos aliados y enemigos
el objetivo es localizar y detener a la
fuerza adversa sin hacerse neutralizar
la coordinación con las otras naciones
es una de las claves del éxito
'defender europe es también una ocasión
para que las tropas prueben el material
militar de punta en las condiciones más
cercanas posibles a la realidad
se trata de un disparo coordinado con
vehículos blindados que disparan con
tropas que desembarcaron cerca atrás hay
tiradores de mortero que también
disparan
[Aplausos]
hoy actuamos frente a un enemigo
simétrico dimensionado tal como nosotros
que dispone por consiguiente de recursos
importantes por ejemplo anti tanques y
vehículos blindados con una relación de
fuerza que nos espera favorable para la
misión la elección del noroeste de
polonia no es anodina para los aliados
de la otan el ejercicio se desarrolló a
cerca del corredor de su walkie este
espacio estratégico es el camino más
corto entre el enclave ruso de
kaliningrado y belarús si el corredor
fuese ocupado la otan ya no podría
enviar tropas terrestres hacia los
países bálticos del otro lado pero el
desafío no es sólo militar los
habitantes de las ciudades de agen y a
unos cuantos kilómetros de la frontera
se toman la posibilidad de una amenaza
muy en serio tal como lo explica este
miembro del club de tiro de la ciudad
hay que preocuparse incluso los romanos
decían si quiere paz prepárate para la
guerra
los miembros de nuestra sociedad
practican el tiro deportivo coleccionan
armas son cazadores
usan sus competencias en sus respectivos
ámbitos
aquí muchos creen que el corredor será
el próximo blanco de moscú
las brisas
hay cohetes que caen cada vez más cerca
de la frontera polaca
espero que la guerra provocada por rusia
terminara pero creo que seguiremos
escuchando sobre ella
estamos en un territorio estratégico
entonces debemos esperar una agresión en
cualquier momento tal como puede ver
toda nuestra vida está aquí
esperamos no conocer la misma suerte con
nuestros vecinos ucranianos
una opinión compartida por el alcalde de
cerny fue reelegido en el 2014 mientras
rusia acababa de anexar crime a un
episodio que no ha olvidado
cuando se vive en el corredor de su walk
y es imposible sentirse seguro debo
transmitirles seguridad a la gente pero
también explicarle que tal vez ya no
estaré aquí cuando la crisis llegue
deberán desenvolverse solos vemos a los
rusos dar de baja a los jefes de los
pueblos ucranianos y probablemente harán
lo mismo con los alcaldes para el la
guerra en ucrania aplaza la eventualidad
de una crisis mayor en polonia pero la
amenaza es permanente y los recursos
hacen falta en la pequeña ciudad
no estamos listos me di cuenta
analizando nuestra situación en nuestra
ciudad contamos con cuatro máscaras de
gas del año 2017 y algunas decenas de
máscaras de gas del año 1978 debo elegir
a quien entregar esas cuatro máscaras de
gas en caso de urgencia y estas nuevas
máscaras de gas se vencerán en el 2027
el alcalde de la ciudad teme que en caso
de crisis solo las ciudades más ricas
tengan la capacidad de dotarse de medios
de protección le hace un llamado a
europa para crear un mecanismo de compra
y repartición de equipos de seguridad
material que podría ser determinante si
la guerra cruzara las fronteras de la
unión